el primer ministro aníbal torres ha
dicho que existen frenos
constitucionales que le impiden al
gobierno del presidente pedro casi o
luchar contra los monopolios y los
oligopolios que según él pretenden copar
el poder político además ha señalado que
esto es un pedido de los peruanos contar
con una nueva constitución pero una
última encuesta realizada por el
instituto de estudios peruanos señala
que la elaboración de una nueva carta
magna se encuentra en el último lugar de
las acciones que pedro casi o debe
ejecutar la iniciativa es respaldada tan
sólo por un 8 por ciento de los
encuestados y hablando de la
preocupación de los peruanos un 56 por
ciento le exige al presidente pedro casi
o luchar contra la delincuencia y un 46
por ciento le pide más trabajo